-Your husband, Hugh,
he's an actor.
-You guys met working together
-We did.
-And then, you have not worked
together since.
And now, he's in this season
of "Homeland."
-Yeah.
-You guys are not doing scenes
together.
-No.
Which is a good thing.
-It is a good thing.
-I think my focus would have
been broken, finally.
You know, that's what it would
have taken.
But no. And he plays a prett
slime-buckety politician guy
-Gotcha.
-Which I enjoyed.
But no, but it was really sweet.
It was fun to visit him
on his set
and share the show with hi
in that way,
from the inside out.
-That's nice.
-Yeah, it was great.
It felt very symbolically
kind of sweet and rich and nice.
-One of the nice things
about this show as well is -
you know, I think in the pas
when we've seen
sort of female spies or female
in the intelligence agency
it's been a lot more
acrobatic
and maybe a little bit mor
unrealistic...
-Yeah.
-...than "Homeland" has
chosen to be.
-No, I mean, I wasn't aske
to do too many ninja moves
-Yeah.
-Which was good.
I mean, I slept with -- people
But, um...
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-But I did it in dowdy
pantsuits, you know?
-Yeah, that's true.
-You know, none of this, like,
cool heels and karate chops, no.
-Yeah.
-But no, it's true.
I think we made an effort
to reflect something
like reality.
-Yeah.
And then, you've been --
is it true that over the years
you've been approached by people
who have claimed at least
to you that
this was the inspiration
for them pursuing maybe
a career
in the intelligence field?
-Yeah, a little bit.
Well, when I first started
researching this world,
and was taken to Langley
and was interviewing peopl
who do this job,
they were
incredibly forthright,
which I found a little confusing
and confounding.
And I asked them, "Why are you
telling me all this?"
And they said, "Well, you know
this is a powerful
recruitment tool.
And we are always recruiting."
And turns out, it was effectiv
because people do stop me
on the street
and say, "Oh, my daughter is
studying Arabic in college."
-Wow.
-Yeah. Like, it works.
-That's a sign that
a show has succeeded,
eight years is a sign
it succeeded,
and also, congratulations.
I heard that you found out there
was an adult film parody
of "Homeland."
-Um, yeah.
-Wow, congratulations.
-Well, yeah, thank you.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, no.
I mean, I thought
"Mad" magazine was cool.
"SNL" was cool.
But like a porn?
-Yeah.
You've made it.
-You know your work has
resonance.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah, so.
-What was it called?
Do you remember?
-I don't know.
I don't know.
And I don't think it was
very impressive.
-Yeah, it wasn't like
a good --
It wasn't like "Boneland"?
-No!
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Right? I mean, that --
-We needed you!
-We needed -- yeah.
I know --
I haven't watched it,
but I do hear in that one,
Cookie Monster does say
"diaphragm."
[ Laughter ]
-I should hope so.
-Yeah.
Hey, thank you so much for
being here.
-Thank you so much for
having me.
-Congrats on eight years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Really nice to see you.
Claire Danes, everybody.